et le créneau la lutte contre la
corruption on s'accélère hier les
autorités ont mené une vague de
perquisition contre des administrations
des fonctionnaires mais aussi des
personnalités politiques le patron du
service de sécurité ukrainien a précisé
qu'il s'agissait d'une campagne pour
porter un coup à l'ennemi intérieur
justice sera rendu à affirmer le
président pour le diverselenski on fait
le point avec notre envoyé spécial à
Kiev Helena Volochine
avec Igor que le mosqui et Arsène avakov
se sont deux ex proches parmi les
proches du président ukrainien vous le
dit mirzuelinski qui n'ont pas échappé à
cette vague de perquisition le premier
est un oligarque l'un des hommes les
plus riches du crâne il a quasiment
porté le comédien au pouvoir le second
fut le seul ministre du précédent
gouvernement a conserver son
portefeuille lors de l'accession au
pouvoir de Zelinski pressé par les
Occidentaux de mettre à exécution l'une
de ses principales promesses de campagne
lutter contre la corruption endémique en
Ukraine Zelinski aujourd'hui n'a plus
vraiment le choix lui qui dépend des
aides occidentales pour résister à
l'invasion russe autre front celui de
l'opinion publique ici en Ukraine le
front des Ukrainiens qui sont prêts à
donner leur vie dans cette guerre non
pas pour que les élites corrompus
continuent de s'enrichir mais pour
assouvir leurs rêves européens ces
perquisitions très médiatisées elles
interviennent un peu plus d'une semaine
après une série de démission au sommet
survenu après que la presse a fait des
révélations sur les affaires de
corruption et cette fois vous le dit
merzelenski n'a pas attendu que les
médias face scandale pour lancer ce qui
ressemble à la plus vaste opération
anti-corruption depuis le début de son
mandat